have an update tonight to a homicide  investigation involving  a two-month-old little girl it happened  saturday near eastern and saint rose  parkway  the clark county coroner identifying the  child as london martin  she died after her father 32 year old  clarence martin jr  threw her from a second floor balcony  during a domestic disturbance  police say martin set the apartment on  fire killing the family dog  the man left the scene and got into two  different car accidents while he was on  his way to the airport apparently  he was taken into custody there martin  is now facing a number of charges  including open murder arson and animal  cruelty